you know how's your anxiety i know we
talked about it last time how's all that
stuff going how you been how have you
been dealing with it
depends on which time of day you catch
me
is it is it sort of like you know in the
mornings it's tough and then in the
afternoon it gets easier one moment and
and it's not this isn't a sexy story but
anybody who's had like really down
moments knows that you somehow at 3am
you end up in a bathroom why are you in
your bathroom
why aren't you still just on the couch
upset but i just ended up in my bathroom
in the bathtub fully clothed so it's not
exciting no water i was just in there
shaking just like
i was tweezing
really
and as i was chatting with my sister
um
i thought to myself why is it that i end
up in the bathroom she goes i do the
same thing
so maybe you could put it out there when
are true anxiety moments where do you
end up it's just your safe place
it's your safe place you're getting a
bathtub it sounds like a safe place for
an earthquake
are you supposed to get in the bathtub
during an earthquake or a tornado what
are you are you ever supposed to get in
the bathtub you're supposed to when
there was that movie where they got in
the bathtub it was
lethal weapon
she pulled out a movie from 4 30 years
ago
they got in the bathtub and it kept
things from exploding on them
maybe that's what it was maybe that oh
yeah maybe that's it
i don't know
but i do i do have anxiety but i'm also
working on ways
to manage it now look i don't know i'm
not a doctor i'm not like someone who
knows everything that's for sure
but it feels like to me
that you got you get anxiety
you're you know you're uncomfortable
there's your ups and downs you go in the
bathroom you're freaking out a little
bit but then you get a job
and everything starts to dissipate or
just
relax a little more is that true
yeah i think i think that is true i
don't want to say that it's all based
around working right but
but it is based around things that for
example if somebody said thinks they
have a sense of purpose
right
um and they can focus all of that
intensity somewhere and say this is what
i'm going to do so depending on what
you've
how you've validated yourself or what
your
what your kind of pattern has been your
whole life if if that's interrupted and
changed then it can create anxiety so
for me
you know i started working as
as a janitor
um when i was 10. wait
wait wait
a janitor
yeah where were you a janitor
my family we cleaned the local
um
no no no it's good i'm just like wow at
10 years old she was doing janitorial
things that's that's cool and that's why
i'm still a bit of a neat freak and i
can't i always clean up after myself in
movie theaters right
um so when i was a kid our family
decided we needed to make more money and
so we cleaned a few of the buildings on
main street after school and everything
and then i really liked having money
so then i was a waitress at 15 as soon
as i could get my card
and then i've been working ever since
and so for me to go from
working and then getting kind of
such such a great job on smallville and
then going on to stephen hope like
i had this rhythm this is what i did i
wanted to go out work come home and not
spend 10 hours at home like
and so
it was a bit of
a bit difficult
not having children but changing
that pattern
right and redefining myself